immigration terrorism to burning issues
debated in plenary following the EU
migration summit in Valletta on November
the 11th and the g20 meeting in Antalya
in Turkey four days later they undertook
specifically to tackle the financing
channels of terrorism and foreign
terrorist fighters that we know very
well is going to be key if we really
want to put an end to this the attacks
in Paris exposed weaknesses in
cross-border information sharing some
Emmy Peas welcome the EU Commission's
proposal to set up a European
Intelligence Agency what we need to see
is that that agencies cooperate with
each other we should also see a
mandatory sharing of important
information between the services in
different countries MEP s also stressed
the need to distinguish terrorists from
migrants refugee dos NOS condon a los
terroristas quyen dais at the earlier
migration summit in Valletta in malta EU
member states committed to three billion
euros to support refugees on the ground
in Turkey but according to one MEP
that's just passing the problem for
someone else to manage we can also spend
this money in order to create conditions
to integrate the refugees in our country
all of these questions will be equally
burning at the eu-turkey summit
scheduled for the end of the month